hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play why alright
this has been a game modern custom for
conversion Moffat people have suggested
to me since I started playing but I
didn't because I'm a dick
look at me I'm a big douche Yolo swag
come on come on come on
markiplier I'm a mental patient what do
you expect
I had tagged on the sounders a wee tad
bit there we go there we go alright new
section yes please now this is a very
highly rated you know full conversion
mod I'm not sure if there are new
monsters or anything I'm think I figure
uses a lot of stuff from numbre tan
shade are reasons
nice nice of the Eve's why not an
amnesia the Dark Descent mod
obviously this takes place in more
modern times as opposed to and these are
itself and other custom stories you're a
patient in a mental facility trying to
be healed oh this looks downright don't
tell me what to do I will don't worry I
haven't forgotten forget your face our
anniversary Aversa yeah see you [ __ ]
time for you to go out grace lots of
people were involved in this
oh no II are those is the names of the
characters of what odds Custis been
three no it has no they don't know of
course I do grace I'm gonna forget
easily with lots of liquor they're
trying to forgive it ever since
biggest mistake of my life getting
involved with you how could I had
everything hello
whoa what I doesn't seem right
Oh someone died when someone's going
whoa that's a little morbid not
necessarily dead though oh yeah yeah it
was me
I confess I did it I couldn't stand it
anymore
marriage is an institution to keep
people trapped and old I don't know I
don't know I couldn't take it anymore
hello whoever was walking here has a
really bad limp and really long legs
okay so it's about as fast as I go big
insane is really ruined my running speed
oh hey hey I'm on a gurney my legs look
a little funky my shoes ain't looking
too good either
oh I'm not crazy you're crazy for
thinking I'm crazy you're the crazy one
oh okay maybe I am Greg oh I know not
sure what's going on here wait a minute
that doesn't seem right I'm going pretty
fast
whoever's pushing my gurney you might
want to mine the corners or something
hey what open it I don't I can't move my
that team I don't know as I woke up I
was someone I didn't know yet it smelled
familiar I felt like being here before
but I couldn't recall any memory of it
where's part is I can't recall any
memory of mine it feels like I'm having
a living nightmare cliche which is
definitely not as it seemed on TV at all
okay and I'm sideways yeah everybody
sleeps on their bed like this I'm not
crazy okay
Derek are they okay maybe I'm good I
said but my head my chest is sideways
okay here we go now finally you don't
remember anything do you David a note to
you I bet you don't they won't let you
remember but please David you have to
help Mary for once in your life think
about Mary I want you to go out there
nevertheless I can't promise that you
won't be seeing nightmares again one
last thing be careful about water who
you believe ooh
thank you me by the way I just have to
mention that this this is really cool is
really cool and also oh my Oh crouched
okay that makes more sense this is
really cool I mean I don't mean to
depreciate the intensity or interest of
this game it is very cool light bulbs
and power it's also very dark in here I
don't think there's anything there looks
good I don't mean to diminish the
quality of this game what I'm saying is
it's a very good and my silliness
shouldn't be yeah
who are you how are you like [ __ ]
how are you yeah no sound ugly so well
you're in the dark mental one do you
remember no no alright don't worry it's
not unexpected to forget things in your
condition and that's why I'm here to
help okay are you ready for our session
today
No why am I alone here because you are a
criminal patient
don't worry my head is just spinning
you're late i'm not a criminai not your
criminal impossibru okay so dr. Sophy is
the doctor in charge kind of reminds me
of cry fear and Simon was going insane
Torino why no one lets me live in my
very own world are they jealous of me or
simply I'm a threat to community I can't
understand my family and my friends want
to heal why would I go back to the life
full of misery I'm afraid they will make
me forget everything I thought the
doctors were trying to help me yeah
interesting hey I can't get it oh whoa
hi hey buddy
it's that penumbra monsters I'm sorry I
won't stare at you you're so ugly you
drove me insane Oh
Brad was a vampire that'd be very
helpful alright so nothing in here
besides a rat guy rat and I'm locked in
the shower
Tara Oh dumb drunks John throw oh I got
turn off all the UH wrong
oh they lock me in here just to tidy up
a bit can't leave all the showers on
stuck who wrong
there we go and that yeah I could see
the correlation between those two
actions now how to get up there this and
out yeah no no no okay so what am I do
oh hello or I could just use that okay I
supposed to take this with me
no all right here we go yeah see ya
obviously a lot of work was put into
this custom story I probably should have
started this playthrough a long time ago
blood I always get sidetracked by
projects hello yeah like about okay so
now we go on our own insane little
venture here because now I have a honky
I'm one of them
Oh a dead guy oh there's a monster out
there what that ha y-yeah Oh some little
guy what that poof interesting
interesting this guy who's very dead but
obviously that's a new that's a new
model interesting so yeah like I said
what what are you doing in there what
are you doing in there old man I'm
coming in there after you
what are you doing at that jug there old
man alright is that the doctor dr.
Walter mess with me
nobody wasn't mess with me hey this
guy's dead too he seemed to have a
mysterious knife in the back of his head
huh
how strange that's cordoned off whoo
hello give me yeah yeah
Oh every mental patient should have
their own personal stash of morphine
that's healthy no finally are you sure
you're sure lady don't tell me to shush
I'm not crazy
something I'm crazy patient continues to
lose some parts of his memories
occasionally especially the ones after
the incident is not unexpected at this
rate however he still shows the
capability of gaining and Perez or
Irving new ones and there is a
possibility that he might remember
everything happened patience progress
should be watched closely and he should
be locked up immediately in need
okie-dokie alrighty then
alrighty then nothing there
who's that it's something just go by I
thought I saw something yeah yeah moldy
bread I'm guessing this is all just
insanity in this guy's mind hey let me
out let me out let me out I'm too cool
to be in here anyway you're too cool -
cool I'm cool dammit don't tell me I'm
not cool oh wait what wait what oh come
on tell me there's something here
there's gotta be some here right
that guy is bleeding from over there -
over there I don't see any like keys or
anything no keys lying about nothing was
in the desk here behind the painting
under these beds maybe there we go
nothing nothing this is weird
well I mean it's not weird obviously I
get stuck all the time what is that old
man doing oh I know maybe that guy's
cell opened up oh no he's still in there
get out while you still can
run for freedom
interesting interesting
there's gotta be something here that I'm
missing something fairly obvious unless
it's really subtle MarkLogic done if
it's not obvious it's probably subtle in
dd-do under the plate no under the Apple
yep on the chairs above the ceiling
under the projector no yeah
calendar nah nope nope no uh-uh no
didn't happen tried opening like taking
that morphine doesn't help no no no yeah
that's about it I mean I don't see
anything else here unless I need to
backtrack even more don't know why
apparently I do no nope can't use a
computer can't use a pencil
yeah I go I'm gonna backtrack a bit okay
you guys probably know what's going on
right you guys know you know oh you know
you know don't you and you're not gonna
tell me you're not gonna tell me under
the bag of trash yard nope nope nope
yeah your mom yeah yeah yeah nap nap
yeah in these hidden cells not not in
the darkness no no
No well what a surprise mark can't get
past first level can't open that can't
open that mark no think good mark no see
goodly mark tick dumbness dumbness level
99 yeah baby I'm a level 99 idiot and
world warcraft yeah yeah my professions
are dumbassery and ass bag douchiness oh
yeah okay so I can't I can't figure it
out I'm too stupid for this so if you
guys can tell me in the comments below
that fantastic I'm an idiot
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that i've done and as always I will see
you
[Music]